bonjour bienvenue au comme un café
faire du tricot manger des crêpes boire
un café jouer de la musique ou tout
simplement discuter et faire des
rencontres tout ça est possible aux
communs café
ouvert depuis le mois de décembre le but
est d'aider les personnes atteintes de
troubles psychiques d'une manière
différente que seulement médical à
l'origine de ce projet l'hôpital de
plaisir et l'hôpital de jour de
Saint-Cyr-l'École dans cet hôpital de
jour il y avait un espace qui s'était
qui s'appelait le lieu des possibles
donc vous accueillais les les usagers et
on se retrouvait et à partir de là j'ai
accueillais les bonnes idées les idées
que les usagers avaient pour essayer de
retrouver du lien social sortir de
l'isolement et notamment un jour un
usager nous a dit mais pourquoi on
ouvrirait pas un café
aujourd'hui le commun café compte
environ 130 adhérents et ouvert le lundi
matin et le vendredi après-midi pour
adhérer il suffit de verser un euro
symbolique
l'objectif est également de
déstigmatiser le handicap je suis
atteinte de schizophrénie affective a
tendance borderline ça m'aide beaucoup
parce que j'étais un peu dans ma bulle
et le commun café comme un corps m'ont
permis de percer un peu cette bulle et
de pouvoir rencontrer des gens peut-être
parfois qui sont dans la même situation
que moi
et donc on va s'ouvrir
[Musique]
on accueille des
usagers qui tiennent le bar qui
accueillent les adhérents qui
pourraient proposer des activités la
destigatisation c'est d'ouvrir à tout le
monde sans distinction de voilà
d'usagers ou de soignants voilà c'est ce
qu'on essaye de limiter voire abolir au
maximum
[Musique]
plus imprévus durant l'année comme des
recettes zéro déchet des cours d'anglais
ou encore un quiz sur la journée
internationale des droits des femmes
tout le monde peut franchir le pas de la
porte et proposer une idée ou boire un
café